[MUSIC PLAYING]
BUKOLA AYODELE:
Today, I'll show you
how to use object
versioning with Cloud
Storage and some examples of
working with versioned objects.
So as you can see, I've got a
storage bucket already set up
named tiny_homes, and
I've put a few photos
of my favorite tiny
homes in the bucket.
So using our console, what we
want to do is we want to type
in the command gsutil versioning
set on gs://tiny_homes.
This will enable versioning
for the tiny_homes bucket.
That tells Cloud
Storage to create
a new version of
an object each time
the live version of the object
is overwritten or deleted.
If I want to stop
versioning, all I have to do
is write this command--
gsutil versioning set
off gs://tiny_homes.
If I ever need to see whether
or not versioning is enabled,
it's very easy to
figure that out.
We can just quickly
write this command,
called gsutil versioning
get gs://tiny_homes.
And as you can see,
if we get enabled,
this means that versioning
is enabled for this bucket.
Now let's work with
some versioned objects.
Here is my tiny_home's bucket
filled with tiny home pictures.
I have uploaded multiple
versions of tiny home
to this bucket.
Only the most recent version
is visible in the bucket,
but I can see all
the versions that
have existed with this command.
If I want to access any version
that's not the most recent,
all I need to do is just to
append the generation number
to the object, like this.
There, now you have it.
You, too, can manipulate
past or present versions
of your storage objects.
[MUSIC PLAYING]